man i love wings in the u.s i love wings
yeah but like you never know
oh my god i'm sorry
you never you never know how many wings
you're getting sometimes which is always
the hard part sometimes they don't say
how many wings you get right which which
i hate and also some of you don't know
how beefy the wings are sometimes you
get like final boss wings sometimes you
get like level one starter pokemon you
like buffalo wings i love buffalo i feel
like in america like
[ __ ] me man like
um because in the uk i feel like in the
uk and europe we have like regular size
wings or like normal like average sized
wings right because uh i've like
somewhere some places in thailand you
order like you order chicken wings or
you order like chicken and you're just
like man this chicken's [ __ ] anorexic
you know like you're in japan all the
wings here yeah you're [ __ ] fighting
to get all the the [ __ ] meat off the
bones man basically it's basically
frog's legs yeah yeah exactly meanwhile
in america it's like oh is this an
albatross
like this boy's
i don't know like i went to buffalo wild
wings once and it's like i don't know if
i like it or not i love buffalo wild see
the problem i have with buffalo wild
wings is that like
they shouldn't call it buffalo wild
wings they should call it buffalo wild
sauce because there is more sauce on
that wing than there is actual wing yeah
okay okay one time i i i've been a few
times because i really like going there
i really like because you get like craft
beer and stuff as well that's fine i
feel i'm like i'm already becoming a 40
year old white dad
i'm already on my way there i love
buffalo wild wings i love craft beer so
much and like wings go so well with it
yeah if it's bone or boneless i don't
mind i just prefer bone bone but i don't
know i just like i just don't like i
don't know the the sauce is like too
overpowering sometimes yeah yeah but
sometimes it depends on what's that
sometimes i have the audacity to be like
would you like extra sauce i'm like no
i'm good sometimes you get a sauce
that's so goddamn good you're like bro i
don't mind if they lathered this on you
know yeah maybe since the sauce i got
was like kind of me maybe like
buffalo wild wings in my experience i've
had a lot of sauces where i'm like this
is this is [ __ ] yeah maybe i just got
the [ __ ] one like sometimes like like
the honey mustard one sometimes honey
mustard is a hit or a mess for me
sometimes it's done right sometimes it
just tastes like artificial as [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah awful um yeah you know what i
really wish we had in japan what
spicy food challenges we have like
there's so many big food challenges in
japan we do have spicy food challenges
where like almost ramen shops
are they like actual challenges that are
like we have a spicy ramen no there's
ones that are like actually really yeah
is that spicy for you joey or like
actually like like
i don't know i think for you guys it
needs to be like nuclear level for you
to be like well that's all
that hits back i'd love to do a video
where i go to like a spicy food
challenge place but i haven't been able
to find anything yet i've seen a lot of
like there was like entire programs on
japanese tv that were about that i saw
one ramen shop that did spicy ramen yeah
but it it didn't like advertise it as
like if you complete it you get
something it was like we just have a
really spicy ramen you can order it oh
like i feel like the part of the charm
of the challenge is that there's like
you get it for free or you know you
right you know there's a challenge to it
yeah yeah yeah there's some kind of some
kind of reward there you know yes then i
can like then i feel like the video can
like have a cycle if you do the only one
i know it's not in japan it's in korea
okay um there's this like restaurant i
think some youtuber did a video on it
but there's this restaurant in korea
that's like uh it serves like tonkatsu
yeah yeah but it's like insanely spicy
tomato and it's like if you complete it
within like a certain time then you get
i think it's like if you complete it
within five minutes yeah you can eat
there for free for six months what and
it's apparently so spicy that there's
only been one person who's ever
completed under five minutes and the
rest of them have gone home
and the rest of them have gone to
hospital what because it's so spicy
apparently when you walk into this
restaurant the first thing they give you
is a carton of milk and like uh stomach
like medicine
you want to do that joey
i'm good what if i find one in japan do
you want to do it shall we
just take a little sip you don't have to
eat it all just take a little bite maybe
i'm done
there was there was a part of me when
when because like i grew up watching a
lot of those kinds of like programs on
tv and
it was hilarious i'm like there was like
one percent of my brain that was like
you should do it for a video yeah yeah
and i'm like curse you
content brain
because you'd actually be suffering for
it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
great now that i've said it on the [ __ ]
yeah i'm gonna get bombarded
awesome i'll foreign it i'll do it if
you guys do with me that's sure yeah
sure sure and just just to show how much
of a fussy i really need because people
because when i had the ghost pepper on
live streams people were like oh that
can't be really it can't be a real ghost
pepper kind of it was a real ghost it
wasn't real
react yeah it's because of your wife
yeah it's because yeah because i'm white
they don't want to believe that i can
handle it because i i've [ __ ] my body
by eating too much of these [ __ ]
peppers yeah but so but i feel like with
with a lot of white people
no no no
no
no it's either like one extreme or the
other it's true because it's either like
people like you who've like actively
searched for it and they've just like
nuked their body or people who say that
water is spicy yeah yeah yeah you had
all the hot ones sources right at your
house yeah yeah and i was like lathering
the hottest one on my burgers and stuff
and like it wasn't that bad like it was
kind of nice like it wasn't that spicy
like and now i watch the show and i'm
like
it's not that bad i want like posted a
burger yeah yeah i want to do the hot
ones challenge yeah but i'd have to like
pretend
oh she's getting kind of hot meanwhile
i'm just like
delicious no because i feel like i feel
like you'd have to like up the ante
because if you just take like one little
dab that's not gonna do anything if you
have if you like [ __ ] coat it then
you'll probably get some kind of
sensation for it i mean i completely
lathered a burger with it yeah it was
fine but i feel like i'd need like
what's the one that's like apparently
horrible it's like the extract isn't it
yeah that's like the extreme one that's
the extra sauce yeah yeah it's like it's
like pure capsaicin yeah yeah yeah yeah
i want to try that
it's not real though it's just your
brain it's your brain making sure you're
right in it yeah like if you if you
think you're gonna go into shock you'll
go into shock
just don't just don't panic just stay
here just don't go and just don't shock
just don't get shot it's similar it's
not real pain you're about to have a
heart attack it's not a real heart
attack just tell your heart to stop
you're scared
just don't die
just get a strong heart it's literally
fake it might never matter it's
literally fake news
why do people die over bee stings just
don't be just don't be allergic just
don't be allergic well okay a beasting
is an actual physical chemical reaction
there's not there's nothing it's all is
not a chemical reaction no it's your
brain it's your brain making the the
pain did you not know that wait wait
wait no because i know i know it's like
not a single person has died from spice
yeah i think yeah i think it's it's it's
it's a reaction that your brain sends to
the receptors saying that you have pain
but there's no actual reaction going on
that's causing you pain it's your brain
telling your body that it's happening
but you can die from the shock
no can you not you could okay so
you you can you can die from going in
the shocker in general right yeah so you
can die from that but like
the pepper alone will not cause you to
go into shock it's like your brain you
panicking and freaking out will cause
you to die right that's like telling
someone who's having a panic attack just
not to panic but like you would
generally you won't die from a panic
attack unless you like have unless
you're having like heart problems yeah
like because it's impossible to die from
a panic attack unless they're like you
have like cardiac arrest yeah yeah yeah
yeah but like the odds of someone our
age having cardiac arrest is like super
low yeah you'd have to really have an
unhealthy lifestyle and also being an
extreme shot i think i'm correct in
saying this i could be wrong there might
be doctors watching this but yeah as far
as far as i'm aware like it's you know
this whole thing don't don't take our
words
don't don't
the opposite of medical advice
as far as i know this whole medical risk
this whole thing of like yeah you can
die like i think you can faint but i
think you can faint from like being like
just absolutely exhausted and and
freaking out and panicking like but like
i'm pretty sure you can't die from it
are we talking about spice
yeah okay i'm pretty sure if you're
healthy and you're under a certain age
and you know you have no heart problems
you'll be fine well suffice to say i
don't eat spicy food because i'm afraid
of dying i just don't enjoy it no i
understandable right like it's just gone
to the point for me where like when i
have something that is like particularly
uh if it's saucy or meaty something
about having spice on it just elevates
it so much no it does there are some
there are some dishes that i feel curry
especially yeah yeah some some dishes i
feel that are just made for spice and
yeah we can do the spice challenge but
like i genuinely
enjoy spices my food with a lot of food
and it depends on the dish right because
like for example if you go to coco
ichiban they have like the spice scale
right
and you can get the level 10. that's
spicy but i feel like that at that level
it's just spicy it's not enjoyable it's
it's spicy for the sake of being spicy
like it just hurts yeah and it it just
ruins the taste of the food yeah i've
heard between level five and ten it
doesn't really change in terms of the
flavor ah it's just more i normally get
seven when i go right it's normally like
a happy medium for me yeah 10 is just
like too much pain i don't know what
they put in it at 10.
i don't i can't explain it the spice
just feels artificial yeah it doesn't
feel like
real spicy just feels like well you're
just kind of adding some kind of
chemical to make this spicy i don't know
what they do to make it more spicy but
like with you know i grew up on
obviously thai dishes and thai food and
it just feels like some dishes are just
made
for spice right
if you remove like the chilis or the
aspects of spice from some dishes you're
losing part of that dish in my opinion
right i saw a picture and it was like a
from a thai restaurant because
apparently thai's known for being the
spiciest foods in the world yeah really
i believe it yeah apparently so and
it's either like thai like indian or
something right or mexican maybe chinese
maybe like szechuan sichuan yeah
szechuan is like a different kind of
spice yeah it's like peppercorns it's
pepperoni spices like nums your tongue
um there was like a it was a picture
outside of a thai restaurant it was like
we will no longer give refunds if your
food is too spicy
and apparent apparently it happens all
the time yeah people have returned food
to thai restaurants is too spicy or in
thailand no no in like uh america okay
no that's how you know it's a true thai
restaurant yeah yeah that's the true
type yeah yeah yeah that i understand
that if it's that spicy you can't eat it
but at the same time it's like
yeah well you are ordering a food and if
you want the native food you are going
to get it yeah yeah like it it it hurts
my soul a bit because at our restaurant
in my family restaurant we have to like
make sure the spice is less spicy dishes
do you offer like the original like
spice of course of course if they if
they ask for it but you know my part of
my soul does they can speak thai yeah
part of my soul dies inside just knowing
that we're serving less spicy dishes to
everyone because they can't handle this
man because that's that's just that's
just not the true dish and to me to me
it does like it does actually hurt the
flavor to me it's like actually like
having sushi without wasabi or something
you know you know you eat sometimes i
don't have wasabi
you don't always need the [ __ ] the
[ __ ] hurts my soul that's my soul
wasabi sucks dick man it's awful it
tastes like [ __ ] well you're not going
to the good restaurant no sometimes i
want 100 yen for sushi man well that's
all that's what you get then that's what
you paid for get off my pants
man can buy a thousand-dollar drip shirt